شكرا راويه وشكرا طاهر طبعا نحن نتابع هذه
الصور الان من مطار الاغوارديا حيث يصل
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وهو يريد العوده طبعا الى فلوريدا بعد ان
مثل امام مدعي عاما الان يصعد الى هذه
الطائره للعوده الى فلوريدا كما من
المترقب ان يكون هناك مؤتمر صحفي للرئيس
ترامب من فلوريدا بعد ان كنا تابعنا هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي في نيويورك لمدعي عامه
الان يدخل الى طائرته هو وصل الى مطار
لاغوارديا في نيويورك وهو الان سيعود الى
فلوريدا طبعا سنتابع معكم لحظه وصوله الى
فلوريدا واي معلومات عن توقيت المؤتمر
الصحفي بحال حصوله في فلوريدا
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور لصعود الرئيس
ترامب الى طائرته الخاصه هو في مطار
لاغوارديا في نيويورك وطبعا سيعود الى
فلوريدا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور كنا ايضا
تابعنا كما ذكرنا المؤتمر الصحفي
لمدعي
الذي طبعا تحدث فيه عن مثول ترامبليوم
ولائحه الاتهام كما ذكرنا في النشرات
السابقه بان هناك اربعه
وثلاثين اتهاما وجهت للرئيس ترامب
وهناك قادر امريكيه يقول بان محاكمه ترامب
يمكن ان تبدا في يناير عشرين اربع وعشرين
ساذهب الى زميلنا
في نيويورك طلال الحاج لنتابع معه اذا كان
هناك اي جديد بعد هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
وابرز ما ج اء في مؤتمر صحفي لمدعي عامه
اليك طلال
نعم لم نستطع ان نتابع المؤتمر الصحفي
المدعي العام لكوننا هنا في هذا الموقع
وكنا على الهواء في واقع الامر ولكن اعتقد
ان الانظار جميعها الان تتجه الى فلوريدا
حيث سيلقي الرئيس الامريكي السابق
بافكاره وتجربه حول تجربته مع المحكمه
الجنائيه العليا في منهات الساعه الثامنه
والربع مساء بتوقيت
المحلي لفلوريدا اي بعد منتصف الليل
بتوقيت جرينتش
متاكد نحن متاكدون انه سيوصف المحكمه بان
المحكمه مسيسه وظالمه تدار من قبل قاض
ومدعة عام يكنان له كل الكراهيه والحقد
ولكن موقف
الدفاع هو الان تحت تحت المجهر محمود
ترامب سيرفضون هذه
هذه الاتهامات وسينصبون على دراستها
وسيطلبون بعد ذلك جلسه لتفنيدها وطلب
رفضها من قبل هذا القاضي او من قبل محكمه
الاستئناف العليا في نيويورك
ولدي شعور بان هذه المحكمه العليا بسبب
كونه رئيسا سابقا سوف تقبل تقبل بالنظر في
هذه الطلبات من جهاز
المحاماه او المحامين
ترامب
وسيقدمون تحديات قانونيه مختلفه لمحكمه
الاستئناف العليا ولهذه المحكمه حتى قبل
طبعا المحاكمه وقبل صدور الحكم محكمه
الاستئناف ستنظر اذا قبلت واعتقلت ستقبل
بصرف القضيه برمتها اذا اذا اعتقدت انها
ظالمه وان هذه
الجرائم ما هي الا جنح ربما
يرتكبها ارتكبها اشخاص كثيرون وكانت
العقوبات هي غرامات ماليه لا جنائيه
كما حصل اليوم مع الرئيس الامريكي اذا ما
رفضت المحكمه محكمه الاستئناف العليا هذا
هذا الطلب من لجنه الدفاع
لرامب سيتحدد فيما بعد
سيحدد موعد
لمحاكمته وقد يكون بعد عده اشهر او على
اقل تقدير شهرين او ثلاثه
هذه لن تكون محاكمه الاولى سيتعرض لها
فستكون هناك محاكمات اخرى بحلول نوفمبر من
العام القادم
2024 وقبل الانتخابات القادمه ميسون اذا
مشاهدينا كنا مع زميلنا طلال الحاج وسيبقى
معنا ايضا لاطلعنا على كل المستجدات
الحاصله امام محكمه منهاتن الجنائيه نذكر
ببعض المواقف التي حصلت خلال هذه الساعه
محامي ترامب يقول لا توجد اي حقائق في
لائحه الاتهام طبعا كنا تبعنا منذ قليل
وصول الرئيس ترامب الى مطار لاغوارديا في
نيويورك عائدا وتابعنا ايضا صعوده الى
الطائره الخاصه عائدا الى فلوريدا بينما
بعض المواقف التي تحدث عنها مدعي عامه حيث
قال بان الاتهامات الموجهه للرئيس السابق
ترامب تتضمن شرائه صمت امراتين وعامل سابق
في برجه ايضا اتهامات ترامب تم تقديمها في
سته عشره صفحه حسب مراسله العربيه وايضا
مدى عام مع نهايه قال بان ترامب متهم بدفع
اموال لعامل في برجه لشراء صمته حول انجاب
طفل خارج الزواج كما قال القاضي بان
المحاكمه قد تبدا في 20 24
في الرابع من في نيويورك ايضا محامي ترامب
كان ذكر بان اتهام الرئيس السابق يؤكد ان
سياده القانون ماتت في هذه البلاد
اذا مشاهدينا هذا الان
مؤتمر صحفي لمدعي عامه
سنحن بانتظاره ايضا
لمتابعته ولكن الان هذه الصور المباشره
بانتظار مدائعه منهتن الذي يدلي بهذا
المؤتمر الصحفي بعد قليل من المرتقب ان
يتحدث عن
مجايات التي حصلت اليوم خلال هذه المحاكمه
للرئيس ترامب حيث كنا تابعنا خلال الساعات
الماضيه متول ترامب امام مدى عامه
واخذت بصماته ومن ثم ابلغ بلائحه الاتهام
وهي المكونه من 34
تهمه ابلغت للرئيس ترامب ومن ثم خرج
الرئيس ترامب من قاعه المحكمه
وتوجه الى المطار عائدا الى فلوريدا كما
من المتوقع ان يعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا في
فلوريدا وكما ذكروا زملائنا في نيويورك
طلال الحاج وناديه بلبيسي بانه الايون
الان ايضا تنصب على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
لمتابعه ماذا يمكن ان يدلي من مواقف
الرئيس ترامب وهناك تخوف من ان يكون هناك
اي تعبير
يحرض
المناصرين على
على العصيان او على التمرد
او على رفض ما يجري خلال هذه المحاكمه
ساذهب الان الى زميلنا من واشنطن بيار
الان الرئيس سابق دونالد ترامب عائد الى
فلوريد ومن المرتقب ان يعقد مؤتمرا صحفيا
ماذا نتوقع
نتوقع كما تحدث قبل قليل الزميل طلال انه
سوف يتحدث الى مناصليه يقول ان هناك محاكم
تعمل لدى الديمقراطيين وهي تحاول ان تقوم
بعمليه قتل سياسي له
وسوف يرى بدون شك انها لدى قاعدته الشعبيه
هناك مؤيدين بالفعل يعتقدون ان كل هذه
الاتهامات المساقه ضد الرئيس السابق هي
موجهه سياسيه ربما نستطيع ان نتحدث قليلا
عن هذه الاتهامات فهناك نص واضح تم توزيعه
من مكتب المدعي العام في نيويورك حول هذه
القضيه واستطيع ان اجز بشكل سريع مضمون
هذه الاتهامات التي سيقت بوجهها دونالد
ترامب هناك اولا السياق العام ما هو تمت
ملاحقته هناك كما ذكرتم قبل قليل اربعه
وثلاثين اته وجهت لي دونالد ترامب وكلها
تتعلق
بتغيير السجلات التجاريه بشكل غير قانوني
ولكن عندما نذهب الى البيان الذي الحقه
المدعي العام في نيويورك بهذه الاتهامات
نرى ان المدعي العام قال ان حاول دفع
اموال
لامراتين واحده تعمل كانت من رموز مجله
بلاي بوي وثانيه هي
وبالتالي نرى هنا ان المدعي العام وضع
قضيتين في قضيه واحده ولم تبقى هذه قضيه
فقط بالاضافه الى ذلك يتحدث في النص
الرسمي الذي قدم للمحكمه عن الشاب الذي
يعمل ايضا في ترامبور وكيف تم الضغط عليه
لشراء صمتهم ويشير البيان الصادر عن
المدعي العام على ان كل ذلك حدث من خلال
الحمله الانتخابيه من الضروري الاشاره الى
ان كل هذا الكلام جاء عن السجلات التجاريه
المتعلقه بمؤسسات ترامب والمحامي
وبالاشخاص الذين
تلقوا الاموال ولكن ليس هناك اي كلام اولا
لم تسمي الاتهامات هاتين الامراتين تمت
فقط المحامي ولم ياتي اي كلام حول استعمال
اموال انتخابيه في
سننتقل الان لهذا المؤتمر الصحفي لمدعي
العام في من هاته بعد هذا الظهر مثلا
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بناء على
على ما خلص اليه
النتائج المتعلقه بهيئه المحلفين اذ ان
هناك 34 تهمه جنائيه
والتي ترمي لاخفاء بعض الجرائم الاخرى هذه
هي طبيعه القضيه الخاصه
اربعه وثلاثون جنايه لتغطيه جرائم اخرى
وهذه تعد جرائم في ولايه نيويورك بصرف
النظر عن عن اي شخص انت تكون فنحن لن نقوم
بالتهاون مع اي جرائم ذات طابع خطير
والمدعى عليه قد قد قام على الدوامه
بتزوير مستندات تجاريه ودفع الاخرين الى
تزويرهم هذه المستندات حتى ان محاميهم
مايكل كوهن قيل بانه قد تلقى هذه الدفعات
لقاء اتعبه القانونيه وهذا بكل بساطه غير
صحيح
وكان هناك ايضا تصريح زائف وغير صحيح الذي
قد ورد شهرا تلو الاخر في العام
2017 في مايو وجون ويوليو حتى نهايه العام
لمده تسعه اشهر على توالي المدعى عليه
احتفظ بمستندات في منزله تحتوي على تلك
المعلومات وقد قال بانه قد دفع لمايكل
كوهن على الخدمات التي انجزها في عام 2017
وقد وقع شخصيا على شركات لمايكل كوهن طوال
الاشهر تسعه بالاجمالي توصلت هيئه
المحلفين ان هناك 34
قضيه بناء على تلك التصريحات الزائفه
لماذا قدم دونالد ترامب هذه التصريحات
الزائفه الادله تظهر بانه قد قام بذلك من
اجل تغطيه الجرائم المرتبطه بانتخابات عام
2016 دعنا ترامب
وهو
الذي كان يتراس
شركته قامه بالتواصل مع بعض الشركات
الاعلاميه قد لجاوا كلهم الى ما يعرفوا
ان يتم
استخدامي اسلوب لمنع اي فرد من الكشف
العلني عن معلومات تضر بطرف ثالث وقد قام
بدفع هذه الاموال من اجل عدم الافصاح باي
معلومات عن ترامب من اجل سداد هذه الدعم
سداد هذه الدفعات فقد تمت من خلال الشركات
الوهميه وتلاتها تصريحات
زائفه وفقا لما اظهرته سجلات التجاريه ومن
احد هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين دفع لهم
من اجل شراء صمتها كانت هو اقل وقبل اقل
من اسبوعين من الانتخابات الرئيسيه
قد قدم 130 الف دولار الى محامي
هذه الدفعه قد تم اخفاؤها عن الجمهور الذي
كان يصوت
وهذه الخطه تعد غير قانونيه وتنتهك قوانين
نيويورك جرائم من اجل التامر على مرشح
بطريقه غير قانونيه
وهذه المئه
مساهمات الحمله الانتخابيه ولم يصرح عنها
ايضا في السجلات المحاسبيه وهذا انتهاكهم
لقوانين نيويورك ولهذا السبب فان السيد
قدم
تصريحات زائفه حول الدفعات التي قدمها
لسيدكون لا يمكنه ان يقول بكل بساطه ان
هذه الدفعات هي نظير اتعاب سيد كوهن
القانونيه بل كانت لشراء صمت
وهذا
وهذا دفعه ليقول بان
دفعه لجعل السيد صهن من اجل سداد هذه
المبالغ لتغطيه عن الجرائم التي تم
ارتكابها في السنه السابقه
وكانت الخطه
التي قدمها تعتمد على تصريحات زائفه
وكانوا ينوون من خلال ذلك الى عدم اظهار
طبيعه
المبالغ التي قد يتم التي يجب الافصاح
عنها امام السلطات الضريبيه
هو الجرائم التي تم تقديمها من قبل هيئه
المحل نهايه المحلفين هي عباره عن جنح
وجرائم فهناك سجلات مزيفه في كل مكان
والتي تعد ذات طابع مهم في منهج التي تشكل
المركز المالي للعالم لذا فان
لذا فاننا نقوم بانفاذ القوانين الصارمه
في بشان هذه الكرم شان هذه الجرائم فان
مكتبي والفريق العام قام
بالوقوف على مئات من السجلات الزائفه التي
ترقى للجرائم
ولهذا فان
قمنا بالاطلاع ومحاكمه على كل من خالف
قوانين السريه المصرفيه وهؤلاء الذين كان
يسعون لتغطيه جرائم جنسيه وقد عملنا ايضا
على توجيه لهؤلاء الاشخاص الذين ارتكبوا
انتهاكات ضريبيه
وهذا
ياتي في صميم تلك القضيه والادعاءات حال
لهذه القضيه مثل القضايا الاخرى
والتي تخص شخص يكذب باستمرار من اجل
التغطيه على مساله اخرى ويجب ان يكون
مسؤولا امام القانون وكما قام هذا المكتب
في اكثر من مره فنحن اليوم نقوم
بمؤازره مسؤوليتنا لضمان بان اي شخص لن
يكون فوق القانون بصرف النظر عن الاموال
او السلطه التي يمتلكها فهذا لن يغير من
المبادئ الامريكيه وانا مستعد لتلقي
الاسئله الان
هناك محاججه فالبعض يقول بان هذه المحاكمه
مدفوعه بطابعا سياسي
اكثر من عشرين عاما وتطرقت الى قضايا ذات
طبيعه معقده
وقمت باجراء تحقيق كامل
بشان هذه القضيه
فيما يتعلق
بتزوير
السجلات التجاريه التي يرمى منها
لاخفاء جريمه اخرى لكن لا نعلم ما هي
طبيعه تلك الجرائم الاخرى التي نفترضها
لقد لقد حددت لائحه الاتهامات هذه المساله
وقد ذكرت في كلمه التمهيديه جمله من
القوانين اولا قانون انتخابات الولايات
نيويورك الذي يجرم التعامر
بشان الترشح للرئاسه بطريقه غير قانونيه
وجمله من الوسائل غير القانونيه بما في
ذلك تقديم التصريحات زائفه
وكذلك اشرت الى قانون الانتخابات
الفيدرالي الذي لديه بعض الحدود القانونيه
[موسيقى]
لن اتطرق الى مساله التهم التي اثرناها
لان الادله هي التي تعد الاساس في اتخاذ
هذه القرارات
لن اتطرق بكافه التفاصيل الى ما حدث
ولكننا كنا قد اطلعنا على هذه القضيه
لمده عده اشهر
والتحقيق لا يتعلق فقط بالسلوك والاداره
التي تخص المدعي العامه وبعد فتره سوف
يكون لدينا الكثير من الادله والشهود وكما
ذكرت فقد قمت بمزاوله مهنتي لعقدين من
الزمن ولا اقوم بطرح اي دعوه قبل ان يتم
التحقيق بها بصوره كامله
هل لديكم ادله جديده بشان التهم الموجهه
كما ذكرت للتو
لقد توفر لمكتبنا الجمله من الادله
الاضافيه لكن لن اتطرق اليها الان
وقبل طرح سؤالك عن القوانين الفيدراليه
وتذكروا ان منحاه هي العاصمه التجاريه
للعالم
وينظروا ونقوم دائما بالنظر بالقضايا التي
تحمل في طياتها اي عمليات التزوير
التجاريه التهم
هناك تزوير حتى في سجلات تجاريه في ولايه
نيويورك
طبيعه اللغه التي تحدثت بها من قبل
المتعلقه بالتزوير تتطلبوا كما حددتها
تماما
سلوكا اجرامي قد تم اخفاؤه هو واحده من
الجرائم المزعومه هي
تتعلق بقانون الانتخابات
الفيدرالي
والتي تعود الى جمله من الاشياء من بينها
الرسائل النصيه وايميل
سوف
سوف سوف تصبح معروفه في قاعه المحكمه في
منهات
انني سعيد لانك اشرت الى هذا الموضوع لان
الامر لا يتعلق فقط بدفعه واحده بل اربعه
وثلاثين سجل تجاري واربعه وثلاثين تصريحا
مزيف واخفاء سلوك
وتصرفا اجرامي فيما يتعلق بسؤالك سابق
المؤامره من اجل تعزيز الترشح احد ما بطرق
غير قانونيه ونقوم بزعمها بما في ذلك
السلوك والتصرف بطريقه غير قانونيه فضلا
عن التصريحات غير
الصحيحه فيما يتعلق بالدفعات الضريبيه
للسلطات المعنيه بدران ليس فقط الدفعه 130
الف دولار شكرا جزيلا
اذا مشاهدينا كنا مع هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لمدعي عام امانه الذي تحدث عن ابرز ما حصل
اليوم في هذه المحاكمه وابرز الادله التي
بنى على اساسها هذه القضيه قال الادعاء في
منهاتا بانه يؤكد انه سيطلب من المتر
اباحيه استور ميدان للشهاده ضد ترامب ايضا
تحدث مدعي عاما بان ترامب انتهك قانون
الانتخابات الفيدرالي ايضا قال بان ترامب
اتبع سلوكا اجراميا خطيرا وبانه لا دوافع
سياسيه حول قضيه ترامب وبانه نفذ تحقيقا
شاملا بشانها كما قال بانهم يضمنون انه لا
يوجد اي شخص فوق القانون وقال بانه ترامب
انتهك قوانين تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه
وبانه دفع عبر شركات وهميه وبانه قدم
تصريحات زائفه لتغطيه جرائم مرتبطه
بانتخابات 2016 كما ذكر بانهم لن
يتعاملوا بتهاون مع كل هذه الاتهامات
الجنائيه
الخطيره كما قال بان ترامب تفعل الاخرين
لتزوير سجلاته التجاريه
وذكر في البدايه بانهم وجهوا اربعه
وثلاثين اتهاما لترامب لمحاولته اخفاء
جرائم اخرى ساذهب الان الى زميلنا غانم من
واشنطن بالنسبه للبيت الابيض دائما يعني
منذ بدايه هذه القضيه ودائما يرفض التعليق
ولكن بعد حصول هذه المحاكمه اليوم
هل هناك اي موقف للبيت الابيض هل هناك اي
موقف
للمسؤولين او المتحدثين باسم البيت الابيض
اخر موقف ظهر من البيت الابيض بحسب معرفتي
هو خلال الاجازه اليومي لكريم جون وهي
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض قالت انها لن
تعلق على هذا الموضوع الرئيس بايدن يهتم
بشؤون الامريكيين اكدت ان بايدن علم بان
هيئه المحلفين يوم الخميس الماضي قد اقرت
لائحه اتهام ضد الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب عرف الرئيس ذلك من خلال وسائل
الاعلام مثل اي شخص امريكي اخر باضافه الى
ذلك عندما كان هناك سؤال حول الحركه في
الشارع والاضطرابات الممكنه قالت ان
الاداره الامريكيه جاهزه لكل الاحتمالات
غير ذلك ليس هناك اي تعليق بحسب ما اعرف
من الاداره الامريكيه نستطيع ان نقول ايضا
انه هو الديمقراطيون بشكل عام يريدون
القول وهذا الكلام كرره قبل قليل احد
النواب من نيويورك نادلر قبله
الرئيس السابق سوف يحضر محاكمه عادله
ويستطيع ان يواجه الاتهامات التي قدمت له
وسوف
يعلن عن قضيته امام هذه المحكمه بالاضافه
الى ذلك هناك الكثير طبعا من الانقسام
والاصطفاف في الشارع الامريكي
الديمقراطيون يعتبرون انها محاكمه عادله
الجمهوريون يعتبرون ان الديمقراطيين
يستعملون العداله
شن هجوم سياسي على شخص مرشح للانتخابات
الامريكيه ويريد ان يصبح رئيسا في العام
الامريكيه يعني يركز 100% على هذه القضيه
ولكن ليس اليوم وانما منذ بدايه ازمه قضيه
ترامب والاعلام الامريكي يركز عليها
هذا الاهتمام المت زايد تجاه هذه القضيه
من قبل الاعلام الامريكي ايضا كيف سيؤثر
على الجمهوريين بشكل عام
هناك اعلان في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هناك الاعلام الاقرب الى الديمقراطيين
وكنت تشاهدين خلال هذا اليوم وحتى هذه
الساعه
بالشبكات لديها
مؤسسات 24 ساعه ومحليه وغيرها
والشبكات المعروفه مثل اي بي سي ام بي سي
سي بي اس معروفه بقربها من الحزب
الديمقراطي ليست قريبه من الحزب الجمهوري
ليست قريبه من التراب بشكل خاص وتضيفين
اليهم طبعا شبكه
جميعهم يعتبرون ان ما حدث من قبل الرئيس
ترامب ربما يكون جريمه وان هذه محاكمه
عادله سوف تكون بالنسبه له بالنسبه
للاعلام الاخر الاقرب الى الرئيس ترامب
والى الحزب الجمهوريه تبنى الكلام
الجمهوري وهو ان
الديمقراطيين انما يستعملون القضاء ضد
الرئيس الامريكي كيف يؤثر ذلك على المشاهد
الامريكي الجمهوريون يشاهدون فوكس
الديمقراطيين
الديمقراطيون يشاهدون ام بي سي ان ان
وبالتالي لن يغير ما حدث في الانتماءات
السياسيه وفي المواقف السياسيه
للناخبين الامريكيين اقله ليس في هذه
المرحله ونحن سوف نشهد من الاعلام
الامريكي التغطيه الكامله لان هناك قضايا
اخرى عالقه ما زالت تواجه الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب لدينا قضيه التحقيق في وزاره
العدل الامريكيه في دوره في ما حدث في
الكونغرس الامريكيه يوم سته يناير في
العام 2021 هناك المحقق الذي ينظر في قضيه
الوثائق السريه التي وجدوها في مارلاجو
وهناك معلومات جديده تشير بحسب بعض وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه الى ان هناك اثباتات
جديده ضد ترامب من انه قد عمل بالفعل على
اخفاء بعض الوثائق السريه التي كانت
موجوده في مره لاغو بالاضافه الى قضيه
نيويورك قضيه اخرى ايضا في جوليا في
جورجيا حول تغيير السجلات للناخبين
ومحاوله تغيير النتائج في جورجيا وبالتالي
نحن سوف نشهد اعلام امريكي مهتم بترامب من
الان وحتى العام 2025 طب هذه القضايا
المتتاليه بحال ايضا بدات كيف ستؤثر ايضا
على الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس ترامب يعني
الرئيس ترامب البعض يعتبر بانه هذه
الاتهامات تجاهه هي تشكل
شيء جيد وايجابي بالنسبه لحملته
الانتخابيه والبعض الاخر لا يعتبر بانه
ستؤثر عليه سلبا لانه
ستتعارض مع
اهتماماته بالحمله الانتخابيه وسيتفرغ
لهذه المحاكمات
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب صنع كل شيء
ايجابي لمصلحته من شيء سلبي جدا هذا ما
اعتاد عليهم منذ العام 2015 وقام به بشكل
جيد جدا خلال عام 2016 ووصل الى الرئاسه
الامريكيه من خلال ذلك وهناك الكثير من
الكلام حول من الاشخاص الذين كانوا الى
جانبه خلال الحمله الانتخابيه في العام
2016 وكيف حول كل الاشياء التي كانت ضده
لتكون لمصلحته
المعسكر معسكر ترامب من الناخبين
الجمهوريين يزيدون حماسا لمصلحه دونالد
ترامب وسوف نشهد ذلك في الخطاب الذي يلقيه
هذه الليله في فلوريدا بهؤلاء الناخبين
الذين يتجمعون في فلوريدا هناك بعض
المترددين من الجمهوريين الذين بداوا
يشعرون بحسب بعض الاستطلاعات اما بالفعل
هذا استهداف ديمقراطي بحق مرشح جمهوري
وبداوا ينتمون اكثر الى ترامب ويشعرون
اكثر على انهم مستهدفه وبالتالي يجب ان
يكونوا معه برلما ان يكونوا مع مرشح اخر
مثل
الديمقراطيون لن يتغير عليهم شيء بالنسبه
للجمهوريين هناك سؤال كبير لو اصبحت هناك
قضايا اخطر على دونالد ترامب مثل علاقته
بالهجوم على مبنى الكونجرس او بقضيه اخرى
مثل قضيه الوثائق السريه للمخابرات التي
كانت موجوده في منزله ربما يكون الموضوع
مختلف وربما ربما ربما وضع كل هذه الاشياء
فيها الكثير من الربما هو لاننا لا نعرف
بالضبط ما سيحدث في الشارع الامريكي خلال
سته اشهر او سبعه اشهر ولكن حتى الان لم
يصل الناخب الجمهوري الى الوقت الذي يقول
فيه ان هذا المرشح ليس هو المرشح المناسب
لي في العام 2024 يكسب الانتخابات
الامريكيه العنصر الفيصل بالنسبه للناخب
الجمهوري هو ليس ما فعل دونالد ترامب بل
هل يستطيع ترامب ان يكسب هذه الانتخابات
في العام 2024 ايضا بعض المراقبين يرون
بان محاكمه ترامب اخذت الولايات المتحده
الى مرحله جديده فيها الكثير من الخطوره
مما يتخوفون هل يتخوفون فقط مثلا الان من
فوضى الشارع ام هناك تخوفات اخرى
قبل ان تبدا وتعطيني الاجابه في سنتابع
نتابع هذه الصور ايضا من مطار فلوريدا حيث
نترقب وصول الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب الى فلوريدا كما من المتوقع ان يعقد
مؤتمرا صحفيا طبعا يشرح فيه ما حصل معه
اليوم في هذه المحاكمه اذا هذه الصور من
مطار فلوريدا حيث نترقب وصول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تفضل بير
اسمحي لي ميسون ان انظر الى هذه المساله
بطريقه مختلفه هو هو ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لقد دخلت في مسار جديد مختلف عن
ما حدث في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الكثير من الاشخاص المهتمين
طبعا بالانتخابات الامريكيه وتعيشه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في القرن ال
21 لم يعيشوا ما حدث في القرن العشرين لم
يرافقوا ما حدث مع بلكلينتون وفضيحته
الضخمه في البيت الابيض مع الفتاه التي
كانت تقوم باعمال التدريب في البيت الابيض
ما حدث خلال ذاك الوقت كان امر خطير وطبعا
الذين كانوا يتابعون الحياه الامريكيه في
ذاك الوقت اعتبروا ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقترب من الانهيار وان هناك باب
جديد فتح امام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الذين تخوفوا مما حدث مع بيلي كلينتون
نسوا ما حدث مع ريتشارد خلال السبعينات
عندما تم تم الهجوم والسرقه على مقر الحزب
الديمقراطي في الانتخابات
وتحول الرئيس نيكسون خلال ذاك الوقت الى
اسير لغرفته في البيت الابيض لانه اتهم
بكل انواع الاتهامات من الكذب والخيانه
والطلب من اشخاص ليقوموا باعمال السرقه
والكسر والخلع وبالتالي الحياه الامريكيه
اكبر من هذا الحدث حتى الان
ليت لا تقارن هذه الاحداث بما حصل من قبل
خصوصا مع الرئيس نيكسون والفتره التي
عاشها الامريكيون خلال السبعينات حرب
فيتنام ومشكله نيكسون وغير ذلك انما يحدث
الان هو هو هو
حدث مهم بدون شك ان فيه بعض العناصر
الجديده ولكن كما يقولون في بعض الاحيان
في اللغه العربيه ليست هذه اخر الدنيا
زميلنا مراسل العربيه من واشنطن على كل
هذه المعلومات على كل هذه التوضيحات وهذه
الصوره الواضحه حقيقه لما يجري الان في
الولايات المتحده شكرا لك
اذا مشاهدينا الان ايضا ما زلنا نتابع هذه
الصور
لمطار فلوريدا نحن بانتظار وصول الرئيس
الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب الى
فلوريدا كما من المتوقع ان يعقد مؤتمرا
صحفيا دائما على مطار فلوريدا لحظه وصول
الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد ترامب الان
ينضم اليه من سكايب عبر سكايب من واشنطن
الكاتب الصحفي بيت الروف سيد بيتر اهلا
بكم معنا هذه المحاكمه انتهت بدقائق قليله
اخذت بصمات الرئيس الامريكي سابق دونالد
ترامب وايضا بنفس الوقت سمع لائحه الاتهام
المكونه من 34
اتهاما بعد هذه المحاكمه كيف يمكن ان نرى
المشهد ماذا يمكن ان تكون الاجراءات
اللاحقه والمواقف اللاحقه
هذه ليست محاكمه بل هي جلسه المثول امام
المحكمه حيث يجب على السيد ترامب ان يقف
امام القاضي ويعلم ما هي التهم الموجهه
اليه وله ان يقر بالذنب او ان يرفض لذلك
وهذا ما قاله وقال انه يرفض ان يقرب الدم
واعتقد ان الان السيد ترامب والديمقراطيين
سوف يحاججون بهذه القضيه في محكمه الراي
العام
لمده اشهر
حيث
قد يستغرق الامر فتره قبل نقلها الى
المحاكمه
للرئيس
ترامب ايضا مدعي عاما هاتا عقد مؤتمرا
صحفيا برر فيه كل الاتهامات التي صاغها
بعد الادله التي تمكن من الحصول عليها
الرئيس ترامب وفريق
المحامين يريدون ان ينقلوا هذه المحاكمه
من محكمه نيويورك الى محكمه اخرى هل من
الممكن ان يتم القبول بهذا الطلب
انني اخشى بان هذا الطلب سوف يرد لا بد من
انتقال لا بد من الانتقال للمحاكمه الى
مقر اخر ولا اظن ان دون الترام سوف يحصل
على محاكمه عادله في منهج تذكروا انه خلال
احتجاجاتي
بلايك لايف
عمده منحه قد انضم الى مجموعه من الاشخاص
امام مجمع الشقق ترامب على مقربه من برج
ترامب
والحديث علانيه في الشوارع لا اعتقده بانه
سوف يحصل على محاكمه عادله لا بد من نقل
هذه المحاكمه الى ولايه ما
بحيث يمكن للناس
ان يتمتعوا باهتمام من اكثر للاستماع الى
الادله وليس فقط للمعرفه اذا ما كانت
مذنبا ام بريان
وخلافا لمقالته بانه لا يجب على ترامب ان
يثبت براءته بل على السيد براجن ان يثبت
بانه مذنب
هذه المحاكمه من الممكن ان تكون بدايه او
هذا او هذا المسؤول الان او هذه التهمه
والقضيه من الممكن ان تكون بدايه لقضايا
اخرى تعد حقيقه اخطر بكثير وسوداويه اكثر
من هذه التهمه هل تستحق هذه التهمه بان
تكون او توصف بالمحاكمه التاريخيه لاول
رئيس جمهوريه
لاول رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
كان سابق او رئيس حالي
اتخذ ان الديمقراطيين يرون بان هناك اهميه
لرؤيه ترامب داخل السجن والجمهوريون كذلك
يرون بانها
تستحق كل هذا الجهد وفقا لما يطلق عليه
ترامب الدوله العميقه بان هناك تامر ضد
خلال حملته الانتخابيه وخلال فتره رئاسته
وحتى منذ تركه البيت الابيض والعمل على
تلطيخ سمعته هناك جمله من المواطنين
الامريكيين الذين ساهموا من هذه الاجواء
الهزليه
وقد تبنوا نوعا من من نوع من المواقف التي
ترى بان عدد الديمقراطيين ان يشعروا
بالخجل من طرح هذه القضيه التي لا اساس
لها من الصحه
ودرر الرمادي في العيون عن القضاء
الحقيقيه
وقرر بعد ان قررت رب ان يترك المسرح
السياسي كما فعل ذلك بصوره جليه بالنسبه
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب يريد ان يترشح
الى انتخابات 20 24 حتى الان هناك دعم
كبير له من قبل الجمهوريين ولكن هذا الدعم
هل هو عن قناعه
هناك مجموعه من الجمهوريين واناسنا الذين
كانوا في هذا الحزب لسنوات طويله والبعض
الاخرين الذين انضموا الى هذا الحزب من
اجل ترامب او الذين يؤمنون بان اربع سنوات
لوجود ترامب في البيت الابيض كندا افضل
من السنوات التي قضاها حتى اللحظه بايدن
في البيت الابيض ولهذا السبب فانه يفضلنا
ترامب اعتقدوا بانه هناك مجموعه من
الجمهورين الذين
احبوا ترامب بصوره مبدئيه وكانوا يرغبون
بالاستمرار
ولكنهم قد يرون بان هناك رغبه بوجودي
مرشحا شابا ولديهم من القدره والطاقه اكثر
من اي مرشح اخر ديمقراطي وهناك اناس اخر
واخرين الذين لا يحبون ويرون بانه عليه ان
يرحل شكرا لك من واشنطن الكاتب الصحفي بيت
الرو ف
اما الان ينضم الي من واشنطن اسامه سبلاني
ناشر ورئيس تحرير صحيفه صدى وطن سيد اسامه
اهلا بكم معنا
هذا اليوم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
مثله امام مدعي عامه هناك اربعه وثلاثين
اتهاما لرئيس ترامب
ولكن الان ماذا نتوقع ما هي الاجراءات
التي يجب ان تتخذ بعدما حصل اليوم وخرج
الرئيس ترامب حتى من دون دفع كفاله
انا اعتقد بانه هذا
الاتهام هو استخدام القانون في السياسه
وهذه قضيه يعني ممكن ان تتفاعل في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على المستوى
القضائي وعلى المستوى السياسي يعني
هنالك من يقول بانه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها كثير من المشاكل وكثير من
القضايا التي يجب ان
تتخذ منها قضايا في المحاكم مثلا قضيه
السلاح وقضيه القتل الذي يستشري في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه السرقات
الفساد خاصه في
المشاريع التي طرحتها الحكومه الفيدراليه
والحكومات المحليه خلال
ازمه الكوفيد كل هذه المشاكل تركوها
وركزوا على
قضيه ترامب هي قضيه يعني مهمه طبعا ولكنها
سخيفه لانهم يعني يعاقبون رئيس سابق رغم
انه انا لا يعني لست من المعجبين بانل
ترامب ولكن اعتقد بانه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اليوم تستخدم القانون في
السياسه يعني خاصه الديمقراطيين يعني
الديمقراطيين اليوم اهدوا دانل ترامب
قدموا الاداره ترامب هديه يعني كبيره جدا
سوف يستخدمها من اجل ان يصبح رئيس امريكا
مجددا انا اعتقد بانه اليوم الجمهوريين
يتكتلون ويقفون الى جانب ترامب اكثر مما
كانوا في عهد ولكن الاستاذ اسامه هذه
القضيه صح انها جنائيه ولكن ايضا تتعلق
بشخصيه الرئيس
بافعال الرئيس وهذا سيؤثر كثيرا على
الرئيس ترامب بحال ادانته
هناك صوره للرئيس ترامب هناك يعني
كما يقال يعني يجب ان يتحلى بها حتى يكون
رئيسا للولايات المتحده
طبعا لا حتى رسل للتذكير يعني فقط ليس
دفاعا ولكن هنالك ربما ثلث الرؤساء
الامريكيين المتعاقبين لاني 46 رئيس هنالك
اكثر من ثلثم عندهم يعني مشاكل جنسيه
واولهم هو الرئيس الثالث في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
اللي كتب القانون والدستور الامريكي
تزوج يعني سرا من من خادمه عنده وانجب
منها ثلاثه اطفال جون كندي كان له علاقه
حميمه مع الممثله الشهيره يعني
له علاقه مع مع احد المتدربين في البيت
الابيض يعني لحتى ناخذ القضيه الى اكثر
وضعت على الطاوله لان الرئيس ترامب يريد
ترشح الى انتخابات عشرين اربعه وعشرين
طبعا طبعا ولو لم يترشح لما كانت هذه
القضيه اصلا على مطروحه على البساط
القانون انا اعتقد بانه انه هذه هذه
القضيه ستمتد الى ما بعد الانتخابات
وسيستخدمها ترامب كما سيستخدمها
الديمقراطيون ولكن اذا كانت القضيه اذا
كانت المنافسه ستكون بين دانا ترامب
الجمهوري
وبايضا الديمقراطي انا اعتقد بانه
الديمقراطيون سيخسرون الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في عام 2024 الى دانه
فما ابقى معي اسمح لي ان تبقى معي ساذهب
ايضا الى واشنطن عبر سكايب مع استاذ بشار
جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي استثم بشار
اهلا بك معنا كيف ستؤثر هذه القضيه اليوم
طبعا كان هناك جلسه مثول الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب امام مدى عاما ولكن هذه
القضيه يبدو بانها ستاخذ وقتا حتى تصل الى
المحاكمه والى
انهاءها
الان كيف ستؤثر هذه القضيه على الشان
الامريكي وخاصه امام هذا الاصطفاف العمودي
بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
وتفاديا لتكرار الكثير ما قيل على هذه
القناه ومن خلال الاستضافات خبراء
ومراسلين استطيع القول بان المعيار الاول
كان وما هذه اللائحه التي احيطت بتكتم
السريه الان استمعنا الى المؤتمر الصحفي
لبراغ وتبين انها ليست في تلك القضيه
المحكمه التي يعني اعتقد بانها ستنال من
الفريق القانوني الرئيس الفريق القانوني
للرئيس السابق وصف بان هذا يوم وكان
العداله ماتت فيه في امريكا يعني تعبيرا
بطبيعه الحال عن دعمه
يعني من يمثل وايضا دعمه لرئيس امريكي
سابق والاهم المرشح المقبل لانتخابات
عشرين المؤشر الثاني الذي بالامكان البناء
عليه هو اي نبره سيتحدث بها واي مضمون
الرئيس ترامب عندما تقريبا بعد يعني بحدود
السابعه بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي في امريكا
سيكون هناك لديه فرصه للحديث اولا للامه
الامريكيه هو دائما يقول امريكا اولا
بمعنى هذه القضيه اكبر من ترامب واكبر من
الحزب الجمهوري هذه قضيه وطنيه ومن ثم
يتحدث لمؤيديه في الحزب الجمهوري والذين
يعني تضاعفوا بمستويات غير مسبوقه اكثر من
ضعف تقدمه على ديسانتس 8 مليون دولار تم
تبرع بها خلال اقل من اربعه ايام كل
المؤشرات تشير الى اننا امام حمله
انتخابيه مثيره بكل المعايير
كما
طلب القاضي هو الا يكون النوع من
تحريك الرؤوس الساخنه او الانوف الحمراء
كان يسمى باتجاه اعمال تصعيد لفظي تؤدي
الى لا قدر الله تصعيد
ستكون شاخصه على ما سيصرح به الان الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب في فلوريدا وعلى مدى
ايضا
سيتعاطى به على المواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
ان كان عبر التروس او حتى مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي والمنصات التواصل الاخرى
حتى الان من جانب الاخر الحزب الديمقراطي
ما صدر لا يطمن على الاطلاق القول بانه
عندما يقول بانه سيحظى بمحاكمه العادله كل
يعلم ان هذا الكلام يعني ليس اكثر من كلام
في الهواء لان هذا الرئيس تعرض لمحاولتي
عزل باسم الشفافيه
والمحاربه من اجل القانون وسياده القانون
تعرض لملف مزور الدوسيه الخاص بهيلاري
كلينتون ولم يحصل اي شيء
التحقيقات التي
اشرف عليها الاف بي اي والمدير السابق
للاف بي اي ايضا انتهت بانه نذكر هذه
الصوره الجريده التي حبلها وقال كوت بانه
تم تبرئته من
السؤال لماذا يعني لماذا يخاطر
الديمقراطيين بموضوع القضاء في الولايات
المتحده المعروفه عنه بنزاهته وشفافيته
وخاصه في هذا التوقيت
ليته كذلك يا
عزيزتي هكذا يتغنى به
نعم تغيرت ولكن للاسف هذا الكلام ليس سرا
كل من عاش بامريكا اجيال وخاصه مرتبط عمله
بالشان العام سواء صحافه او سياسه او قضاء
يعلم ان الامور ليست على نحو الورد الذي
توصى به والا اين تقديم جورج بوش الابن
مثلا لما يتعلق بحرب العراق اين تقديم
المتورطين في الربيع العربي المشؤوم في
دعم الارهاب في دعم السلاح حتى التحدث الى
جانب ارهابيين ودعهم اين اين هو القضاء
الامريكي والدولي في ذلك بعد ذلك نتساءل
اين هو القضاء من هنتر بايدن اين هو من
بايدن الذي تبين الان وبتحقيقات لجان
كونغرس متخصصه بانه حصل اكثر من مليون
مليار دولار بمئه مليون عفوا دولار من
الحكومه الصينيه من حزب الشيوع الصيني اين
هي عبقريه هنتر بايتن حتى يكون خبيرا
للطاقه مع اوكرانيا ومع الصين بشار انت
تشكك كثيرا بالقضاء الام ريكيه في هذه
الحاله
للاسف يا سيدتي الذي يقرا بانصاف وبتجرد
يعرف ان مشكلتنا قديمه قديمه جدا لان
للاسف المعارك السياسيه فيها اثناء
الاعلام والقضاء شكرا لك من واشنطن كنت
معي عبر سكايب بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي كما كان معي من واشنطن اسامه
سبلاني ناشر ورئيس تحرير صحيفه صدى وطن
وطبعا نشكر زملائنا من واشنطن وايضا طلال
من نيويورك شكرا لكم على طيب المتابعه في
امان الله